When you start your pattern, there is a rhythm to your pattern. It's not just really fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through. There's a slow, fast, and you get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So, each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can. If you're a black belt, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3. So, 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So, say your pattern speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now. Say your rhythm was only about average.
It wasn't amazing. It might be just a 1.3, but let's say you didn't shout very loud. So, your expression of energy, your average was 1.3. It might drop to say, let's say, a 1.0.
I think I got enough.
Okay, we're going to practice reading.
This time, we cannot pause the video, but you're going to be doing minor errors.
Okay.
And then major errors. And then right after the performance would be reading your power and speed, coordination of rhythm, and expression of energy.
Okay. And you're ready?
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.